moving on
our main story tonight concerns
bankruptcy you probably know it from
being the worst possible outcome on
wheel of fortune aside from hugging pat
sajak or winning a mitsubishi mirage
or maybe you're familiar with it through
ads for bankruptcy lawyers like this one
once upon a time there was a fair maiden
named mary
mary lived a storybook life until her
prince charming was smashed from his
steed
then her castle came under siege and the
cries of assault were vexing
her champion had been gravely injured
and the pox had fallen upon her house
i've helped thousands of clients like
mary and i can probably help you get a
fresh start
wow there is a lot there from an
unmarked van
fully mean girlsing mary's husband to
him surviving
what appear to be surprisingly minor
injuries to that lawyer
claiming he's helped thousands of
clients like mary meaning that in the
chattanooga area there are somehow
thousands of women who've watched their
husband get stomped by a cargo van
and then take what can only be described
as a gatling gun of mail to the face
if that is true they've got a way more
lucrative lawsuit than a bankruptcy case
what that ad is promising though is
really attractive a
fresh start from your debts and it's
something a lot of people have turned to
over the past decades the number of
personal bankruptcies filed each year
has ranged from about 800 thousand
to one and a half million and many worry
that once the current pandemic
assistance stops
more and more people will need the type
of help that bankruptcy offers because
very basically bankruptcy is a legal
procedure by which those who are deeply
weighted down by debts
can get out from underneath them and
then have a chance to start anew
which is good although it does come with
some consequences it will be on your
credit report
and there tends to be some social stigma
attached as exemplified in this clip
from shark tank jeff i understand your
decision to go bankrupt
cleans the slate but it carries
a weight you'll never have a bank jeff
ever
to me you're radioactive
there are a million people out there who
are going to get the wrong message from
what you're saying no they're getting
the right message
they should not go bankrupt well hold on
because that is a
terrible lesson and you kevin o'leary i
hardly want to be calling someone's
decisions
radioactive given that you invested in
companies with business models like
put your face on a potato look like an
idiot on a unicycle
and toy guru the netflix for toys whose
mascot
always looked like it was searching for
a place to take a and which
interestingly
filed for bankruptcy so i'm
sorry kevin but to me
that makes you radioactive i'm out
but that broad brush stigmatization is
common and
completely misguided because bankruptcy
is not solely caused by bad decisions
it's often caused by bad luck
unavoidable challenges like job loss
divorce surprise medical bills or
perhaps even you know
a once in a century global pandemic and
despite bankruptcy often being
characterized as an easy out
the way it's currently set up it's
sometimes not an out at all
as this couple learned before you're
done and over with you're definitely
looking to spend at least a thousand
dollars
to fi to claim bankruptcy um
we don't have a thousand dollars so
you can't afford we can't afford
bankruptcy to go bankrupt
yet we're fifty thousand dollars in debt
so what do we do yeah a lot of people
can't afford to go bankrupt a true
sentence that
fundamentally doesn't make sense like
sonic drivings advertising cities
whether a no sonic locations or
the sequel to now you see me wasn't
called now you don't or
elon musk doesn't his cars i mean
come on that is the face of a man who's
at the very least measured the
circumference of the charging point
so given all of that tonight let's take
a look at personal bankruptcy
our modern bankruptcy code was enacted
in 1978
interestingly around the same time that
the credit card industry began to enjoy
a period of steady deregulation which
worked out
very well for them because they marketed
themselves aggressively and
during this time consumer debt began to
sharply rise
and what the industry clearly wanted was
people stuck
in a lucrative cycle of minimum payments
late fees and
interest hikes what they didn't want
spoiling that was people cutting the
cycle short
through bankruptcy so by the late 90s
they were lobbying senators like chuck
grassley hard to curb
what they framed as bankruptcy abuse
basically arguing
the people who could afford to pay were
using bankruptcy as an easy way
to not pay bills and then pass the costs
on to the rest of us
and grassley seemed more than happy to
repeat some of the industry's talking
points
there's not a single family in america
low income
or high income that is not paying part
of the cost
of bankruptcy 40 billion dollars cost to
the economy
every year 400 for a family of four
wow the average family pays 400
a year because deadbeats abuse the
system grassley dropped that shocking
fact with the confidence of a man who
would later tweet from his government
account
windsor heights dairy queen is good
place for you know what
the thing is though that 400 figure is
total nonsense
no one knows for certain where it came
from and despite it turning out to be
demonstrably false the credit card
industry pushed it
hard to create a narrative of widespread
irresponsibility and abuse around
bankruptcy
but it's a little hard to take moral
grandstanding from credit card companies
who were
all too happy to help people get into
significant debt
even if they had just declared
bankruptcy
barely out of bankruptcy court joan
brunette opened her mailbox and there it
was
the chance for a shiny new credit card
the first of many
it looked like an easy three thousand
dollars and
i think i hung on to it for a day and
then i thought oh
no you're not going to be that crazy the
banks are giving out credit with a
reckless disregard
for the consumer's ability to repay yeah
that max weinberg impersonator is
absolutely right and so by the way was
joan
who self-restraint i really do admire
there imagine the expenditures that
i could have avoided by simply saying no
john you're not going to be that crazy
ask yourself do you really need this
item
but years of lobbying by the credit card
and banking industry ultimately resulted
in a hugely significant 2005 bankruptcy
reform
bill which made it far more complicated
to fall for bankruptcy than it had
previously been
which in turn made it far more costly
which meant
many people ended up in a situation
where they couldn't afford to go
bankrupt and to understand our current
system a key thing to know
is that there is not one main kind of
personal bankruptcy there are actually
two chapter 7 and chapter 13.
chapter 7 is what you commonly think of
as bankruptcy your debts are
mostly wiped out and while you can hold
on to a few essential assets
below a certain threshold the rest can
then be sold
to pay off your creditors it takes a few
months to complete but then
you do get your chance at a fresh start
chapter 13 however
is different that is more of a
reorganization of debt
basically your finances get examined to
work out
how much you can afford to pay into a
repayment plan for three to five years
and
if you make all the payments in that
plan at the end of it
your debts do get discharged and this
does have its benefits you don't
have to give up assets like a house or a
car but
and this is a huge but if you miss even
one payment your case could be dismissed
and the whole deal is off you're
essentially
all the way back to square one and the
uncomfortable fact is
this happens in most chapter 13 cases
because only a
third actually make it all the way to
discharge
and chapter 13 is also actually much
more expensive to file
because while attorneys charge on
average about thirteen hundred dollars
to file chapter seven
for chapter 13 they generally charge
about 3 800.
so you might be thinking well if chapter
13 is more costly
more difficult and less likely to get
you a genuinely fresh start
why would anyone choose it well for some
it might be the right fit remember
it gives you a chance to keep your house
which you might need to live in
and your car which you might need to
work but for many many more
chapter 13 despite costing three times
as much in the long term can actually
seem like the better financial option
when you file because
chapter seven generally requires you to
pay
lawyers up front whereas chapter 13 can
be different
as law firms can be eager to point out
to you is debt
constantly on your mind are you looking
to get a fresh start financially
then call the bankruptcy attorneys at
wooten and woot we even offer a no money
down chapter 13 plan
okay first get the out of my void
wooten
i know i don't technically own the
concept of sad white emptiness
jared leto's got the market covered on
that one but i will be damned
if i let this adult who looks like he
just made a wish to be big steal my
whole vibe
but the point here is if you are already
in a bad spot with your finances which
you probably are
if you're considering bankruptcy no
money up front
might not just sound good it might be
your only option
the worry is that some lawyers guide
their clients to the more expensive
chapter 13
when they'd actually be far better
served with chapter seven and if you
know anything about america
it will not surprise you to learn that
when researchers ran an academic
experiment they found attorneys were
more likely to recommend chapter 13 to a
hypothetical black couple
caused by the way reggie and leticia
than they were to a hypothetical white
couple called
todd and alison i'm putting aside the
question of whether the research has
plucked
reggie and leticia from the big book of
stereotypical but hopefully not
offensively so black names the fact is
the study's findings do help explain why
nationally the odds of black debtors
choosing chapter 13
instead of chapter 7 were more than
twice as high
as white debtors with a similar
financial profile so even
bankruptcy discriminates against black
people which is coincidentally the cover
story on this month's issue of
yeah no magazine and the fact
that people are often pushed into the
form of bankruptcy with
far less successful outcomes mean that
they can end up having to fold
bankruptcy again
down the line and knowing that makes it
a little hard to see financial experts
like susie allman
broadly frame repeated filing as a moral
failing
most people who claim bankruptcy once
claim it
twice so if you are claiming
bankruptcy you have got to learn because
if you get yourself into that situation
again
if you go out and you rack up all this
credit card debt and all the stuff
again and you have to claim bankruptcy
again
then i say shame on you
wow susie is offering repeat bankruptcy
filers the
shame on you normally reserved for dogs
who peed on the carpet and
nosey pharmacists in magnolia who've
asked julianne moore
one too many questions i have sickness
all around me and you asked me
my life
have you seen death in your bed in your
house what's your decency
and then i've asked questions
what's wrong
you suck my dick that's what's wrong and
you
you call me lady shame on you
shame on you
but a few things first experts say that
orman's claim that
most bankruptcy filers file twice is
just wrong but much more importantly
even those who do end up filing a second
time often do so
due to factors that have nothing to do
with recklessness like for instance
getting pushed into a chapter 13
bankruptcy that was not right for them
and there is something else that can
significantly limit the help
that bankruptcy can provide because
there are whole categories of
non-dischargeable debts debts that even
bankruptcy
cannot get rid of you typically can't
wipe out debt from criminal penalties
taxes or child support through
bankruptcy and there is another
massive category as this woman learned
thirty-one-year-old radmila sulimonova
graduated with a masters from new york
university in 2008
during the depths of the great recession
jobless she quickly defaulted on her
eighty thousand dollar
student loan bill oh well i'll just file
for bankruptcy like everyone else is
doing hahaha
and then you realize no the only way to
get away from your student loan
debt is to die yeah and to communicate
just how bad student loan debt is as a
generational dead weight on millennials
i guarantee you
anyone with student loans watching this
right now heard 80 000
and thought yeah i don't know i've i've
heard much worse
because yeah she could have bought this
entire three-bedroom two-bathroom house
in indianapolis but
who really needs a place to live when
you have a framed eight and a half by
eleven piece of paper with your name on
it
that can just like a house keep you safe
from the rain
and if all that weren't bad enough our
current system adds insult to injury
through
mandatory credit counseling courses
which can be exactly as patronizing
as they sound even bankruptcy judges
have called them
inane and a procedural hurdle without
value or consequence with one
even noting a course referred
participants to the local library
for resources on bankruptcy and
recommended they seek a job
making higher wages and i'm sure they
had never thought of doing that
before it was very cleverly pointed out
to them and if
it seems that these courses may have
limited value
one that we found online even seemed to
reluctantly acknowledge that fact
your attorney may have gone over your
particular situation with you in their
office already
perhaps they explained why credit
counseling will not work for you
many debtors therefore believe that this
mandatory credit counseling exercise is
pointless we hope instead you will take
a more positive view of this mandatory
course
oh you hope so do you that's basically
an admission that the whole thing's a
waste of time although quick question
here
why is the attorney there cartoon me
he's wearing my glasses he has my bangs
he's negging an unwilling civilian while
waving around a boring amount of
paperwork the guy
is more me than i am and while at best
an objectively hunky cartoon
lecturing you on your finances is
annoying at worst it can be actively
insulting because the assumption in
these courses
is that you are in this position due to
reckless personal behavior but imagine
how that argument feels if you like this
woman went bankrupt after having to
leave your job
to take care of your son who died from
cystic fibrosis
in september we sat down to take the
credit counseling course
and it was sort of a slap in the face
honestly
and we have not yet finished that course
we logged off
and needed to walk away from it for a
little while and we'll need to do it
again
after we actually go through the filing
process and meet with the judge
it's a requirement after you file as
well so that you can
i guess get an idea of how to not do the
same thing again in the future
so which is an incredibly
hurtful idea that i'm not looking
forward to no
of course you're not because having a
course suggests that there is a way not
to have your child
die again in the future is a
insult and it is terrible that she not
only had to go through that but
then had to rehash it in the senate in
an attempt to get that requirement
changed which by the way
it wasn't and the truth is so much of
what is wrong with our current
bankruptcy system
stems from that 2005 law that i
mentioned to you earlier
expanding the non-dischargeability of
student loan debt that was in there
the mandatory credit counseling classes
that was in there too the law also made
bankruptcy harder to complete
adding over a dozen ways that someone
could make a technical error
and be dismissed it was a huge win for
the credit card companies
and for all the assurances from grassley
and others that it would
target high-income people abusing the
system without
hurting those of lesser means after it
passed bankruptcy filings dropped
disproportionately in poorer
neighborhoods with filings there
decreasing 32 more than in rich ones
showing that as always when things are
designed to become harder for everyone
for the rich
they just become a bit more expensive
and for the poor they become
basically impossible so what can we do
here well
ideally the people responsible for that
2005 law would acknowledge that our
system badly needs fixing and
coincidentally
one of the most prominent backers of
that law is actually the
president now joe biden is from delaware
home to some of the biggest credit card
companies and his support
was crucial in getting the 2005 law
passed
and it is not like he wasn't warned that
it could lead to trouble
when it was being debated elizabeth
warren then a harvard law professor
studying bankruptcy
testified about how medical debt ruins
people's lives and how this bill
could significantly hinder their one
remaining chance to get out from
underneath it
and joe biden kept shifting focus back
to the poor
creditors who wouldn't get their money
until we fix the broken health care
finance system right those families have
to turn
somewhere and that means now
they turn as a last-ditch effort to the
bankruptcy
and that means they turn to asking the
people
that they borrowed money from
to pay for their health care costs right
we're going to ask the gas company the
drugstore the automobile dealer
to pay for the broken
system okay but that's not really how
this works
is it it's not that we're living in some
small town in the 1920s racking up debts
to the corner store for groceries
the butcher shop for meat and the local
pharmacy for cough drops laced with
weapons grade cocaine
no we're living in a world where medical
debt is out of control
and people have envelopes rammed through
their door every day screaming
that they're pre-approved for a credit
card oh look this one has
snoopy on it now the good news is in
december elizabeth warren proposed the
consumer bankruptcy reform act which
would
completely overhaul our bankruptcy
system it would eliminate excessive
paperwork needed for filing thereby
lowering attorney costs it would make
student loan debt dischargeable
it would get rid of the requirement for
a credit counseling course and
it would combine chapter 7 and 13 into a
new more flexible chapter 10. it's a
combination that would be an improvement
sort of like burger king's chicken fries
a little bit chicken
little bit fries all in a box that looks
like i asked my kids to draw me from
memory
and while biden has broadly expressed
support for warren's reforms the fact is
her plan is unlikely to pass in its
entirety because
it would need 10 republicans in the
senate to get on board because
democrats like joe manchin and kirsten
cinema are still in a death cult over
the filibuster for some reason
but the fact is something big needs to
happen here
because we badly need to get our broken
bankruptcy system working again
for people who desperately need a
lifeline and meanwhile
while we wait for congress to act the
very least we can do
is offer an alternative credit
counseling course that isn't quite so
insulting
hello there i'm the cartoonist's
steamiest wonk
if you're watching this video chances
are you've hit hard times
maybe your husband was pancaked by an
unmarked cargo van
or maybe you lost your job due to the
coronavirus and that fateful day in 2019
when one bat that other bat
either way
you're saddled with debt right now and
you're looking for a fresh start
thankfully you found bankruptcy less
that is your debt is
student loans in which case you should
think about faking your own death
because odds are
you're as as this bat under
current bankruptcy law you're required
to complete
this credit counseling course and the
key thing i'm here to tell you is
there are two main kinds of personal
bankruptcy
chapter 7 that's the thing you think
offers bankruptcy where typically most
of your debts can be discharged
and chapter 13 which you might assume
works similarly
though anyone who's been through it
knows that it doesn't
and if all this seems needlessly
confusing it's because it is
the whole system is currently designed
to be so discouraging that eventually
you say
it and give up are you okay
so instead of watching a condescending
series of videos about
how to make a budget why don't we both
make better use of this time and enjoy
this video of a man feeding a pack of
raccoons individual hot dogs
yes yes
yes look filing for bankruptcy will
never be as enjoyable as a raccoon
eating a hot dog
but at the very least it should be that
simple
bye
that's our show thanks so much for
watching we're off next week back may
2nd good night